with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
shield your cloud with verifiable
advanced platform security then stay
tuned because here's the rewind if
you're like me you probably run a bunch
of virtual machines and you're using a
mix of your own hardware some public
cloud and resources maybe both and of
course you want to keep them safe but
are they safe are you sure one major
challenge with this is just how quickly
we see attackers jump into action with
publicly accessible VMs we notice
attempts to penetrate new virtual
machines in under five minutes once
they're publicly exposed an attacker
wants to get to your data take over your
resources or even better get your
credentials and then they can easily do
both at once to help keep your VM safe
Google cloud provides shielded VMs this
new option can protect your resources
and give you assurances that your
virtual machines only run in a safe
secure and expected state how does that
work a shielded VM extends the
defense-in-depth model to the very
lowest level establishing a route of
trust with the bootloader and the
firmware this is important because if
you can't trust your OS then you can't
trust that things running on top of it
your Trojan detection audit logging
privilege separation or antivirus at all
so the trust needs to start before the
OS even begins which is why we need a
hardware root of trust to keep these
fundamental components safe enter Titan
a chip designed by Google to secure the
boot process each Titan chip as it gets
made has a machine identity key burned
into it and can further attest that it
has the correct firmware running on
itself and its host machine Titan also
validates the signature of the
bootloader and kernel binaries so it
will stop boot if the signatures don't
check out this lets shielded VMs assure
integrity from the very first
instruction executed we go beyond secure
boot and give you measured boot
providing insight and control into the
entire boot sequence from firmware to
bootloader to kernel binaries putting
all this together allows you to validate
a virtual machine as a safe environment
for your data your code and
secrets we think everyone should use
shielded VMs there's virtually no
performance impact they reduce the
trusted compute the fully support live
migration and patching and they work
across any hardware thanks for watching
you can see the full talk link in the
description below subscribe to the cloud
YouTube channel for more next rewind
videos
[Music]